today's topic double-oh-seven has now
become a black female so now we have
jamie's bond doula in the new James Bond
film okay so you don't do that James
Bond do is a dope name [ __ ] did you say
I look like a bomb doula a little bit of
Afrobeat in it you know I'm not gonna
make this about James Bond I'm gonna
make this about race bending of any
character pause any of them okay
everyone here when they saw that the
black double-oh-seven was coming I saw a
whole bunch of people behind yeah we did
it Little Mermaid yeah we did it
it just Alba playing in Norse mythology
character yeah we did it right everyone
is jumping that they're now taking over
these traditionally white characters and
what is the logic behind this they say
that oh it's a fictional universe it's a
fictional character the race is not
important to the character so it doesn't
matter if you change it why were you
guys mad when you saw Scarlett Johansson
playing that character from ghost in the
shell' the irony is that Ghost Michelle
is an anime about how our personalities
and individuality transcends our
physical body right right you guys are
mad about the race of the character in
this anime where it doesn't matter what
the race of the character is right you
said if you want to change race doesn't
matter because it's a fictional universe
Scarlett Johansson when Scarlett
Johansson comes in uh yeah it does
matter cuz she's a white woman your
argument is not beasts and logic is
based purely in there's a benefit shoot
if it does then you're gonna bend the
rules and if it doesn't then you're
gonna enforce the rules
notice how when they change a
character's race it's characters who've
been run through the wringer who've been
established one way for years for years
and now they give you this new character
who looks completely different who set
up to fail and you know what's funny
yeah but we eat in it's a win you're
eating out of a dumpster you're eating
sloppy seconds you're eating out of a
dumpster there's not a win that is not a
win give it even if you're eating if
you're eating out of the dumpster
something I've been using abuse and
reviews and reuse and
you cannot you cannot no it's not
winning you're gonna be fooled you're
gonna be full of [ __ ] that's not a win
yeah but we eat it out of a dumpster
truck god I've done did tell Oh
but then soldier boy tell them you by
that same logic you know what black
panther can be a white person Black
Panther could be an Asian man
Black Panther could be an Arab person or
a Baba it said in Africa blob it's a
fictional universe that was your logic
because it's not real why do our
real-world logic applies and all the way
in Africa there are all bye no black
people there are white South Africans
there are Arabs in the north right you
know what kinda is not a real places
what kind of fake and I want to talk
specifically to black people about this
you guys are celebrating Hollywood and
what they're doing with these race band
with the race changes with all these
characters meanwhile in these very films
that you are celebrating they are
destroying the legacies of black
characters that have always been in
black and always been amazing you guys
saw what they did to Monica Rambeau in
the Captain Marvel movie Monica Rambeau
should have been the Captain Marvel they
had this white feminists right Carol
Danvers that Miss Danvers okay and she
was Captain Marvel right but you didn't
know this Monica Rambeau the young black
woman in the movie is actually
technically supposed to be just as old
as Carol Danvers but instead they make
it her child she was born to two people
which I think it was Frank and something
else
Rambo right she had two parents in this
movie they made her a black single child
they went straight to that stereotype
they took Monica Rambeau who was not
only the leaders of the Avengers at one
point she Captain Marvel at one point
they made her a child and they made her
look up to this wife feminist despite
the fact that in the comics she never
really had contact with Carol Danvers
so in propping up this new [ __ ]
legacy now they were destroying the
black original characters and you think
of Hollywood's looking out for your best
interest you think Marvel gives a [ __ ]
about black people they just want to
sell diversity and you guys are eating
that [ __ ] up because you see white
people getting mad and you like stick it
to him [ __ ] him they're racist and I'm
like you don't even realize you being
fed sloppysecondz
you ever seen that human centipede I
didn't seen it but it's basically when
one person eats and shits in the other
person that's what happened he's one of
these carrot
through that and they got [ __ ] on and
shot people last person on that human
centipede so you guys have a lot of toys
to play with now in the future including
the x-men right it's funny that people
call it the x-men there's a lot of
female female superheroes in that x-men
group so I think it's outdated do you
know where the name x-men comes from
Charles Xavier gave the name to mutants
who showed extraordinary powers that
these people were above human ability so
instead of calling human they called
them an x-men it wasn't about males
it wasn't about females it was about the
human race but she doesn't know that
because she's not familiar with the
material she just sees it as a cash grab
and so she's gonna change the name x-men
to change something goofy is [ __ ] and
then she's gonna think she's making
progress when she's just destroying the
legacy of characters in the name of
social justice when these characters
never meant anything sexist by it was
never anything sexist in its Genesis but
they wouldn't know that because they
don't follow the content [ __ ] all this
race bending leave the characters as is
that's all I'm gonna say about this I
hope I never have to address this again
I'm not gonna do any more videos I don't
care who else they change I'm done with
it covered you [ __ ] characters
hey not only invent listen make real
characters we want to hear about Russian
superheroes okay we want to hear about
superheroes from Slavic countries want
to hear about superheroes from Asia one
hear about superheroes and real folklore
from Africa that's I don't need you guys
to take too seriously white characters
encase them and use your fumbled up
Longet logic to change them because you
think that's gonna make me happy [ __ ]
out of here I didn't want to see the
first black Ariel I didn't want to see
the first black Teletubby I don't want
to see the first black Bachelorette I
don't want to see none of that [ __ ] make
original stuff man in the bugle you
can't take our stuff because if you do
it's racism but when we change your
stuff it doesn't matter cause your boys
in the hood let's make them white dudes
yeah what white people can live in the
hood boys in the wood for white man
camping boom oh man what do we call so
point so lame
yeah plane
[Laughter]
[Music]